ja lange haben die apple fans darauf
gewartet auf das neue iphone 12 jetzt
konnte man das iphone 5 schon seit dem
oktober kaufen aber die modelle die wir
ihnen jetzt sagen dafür braucht man auch
ein bisschen geduld denn die kommen erst
diesen freitag in die läden und sven
stein hat sie dabei hallo das hat einmal
das iphone 12 mini und einmalig darf
nicht wackeln und füllt promax der erste
unterschied klar fällt auf die größe
aber es kommt ja auch auf die inneren
werte an was unterscheidet die beiden
geräte dennoch voneinander
also ich glaube wir uns erstmal ganz
klar sagen dass ich ganz vieles gar
nicht unterscheidet dass es wichtig zu
wissen wir haben ja nicht ein großes
hochgezüchtet das gerät und ein kleines
abgespecktes sondern wir haben zwei
geräte die haben beide 5 g funk an bord
der beiden sehr schnellen prozessor an
bord haben natürlich magsafe also diese
magnetische funktion dass man also
zubehör hinten an der rückseite
anbringen kann
aber wenn wir über unterschiede quasi im
inneren reden dann müssen wir natürlich
über die kamera sprechen dass promax
heißt nicht umsonst pro weil es eine
extrem hoch gezüchtete kamera hat und
ich habe beim testen beim fotografieren
eigentlich wenig unterschiede verstellen
können vielleicht ein bisschen so im
nachtmodus bei der promax kamera im
vergleich zu dem zwölf mini aber wenn es
ans filmen geht ist dieses gerät das
große mit seinen drei kameras einfach
wirklich hervorragend und deutlich
besser noch mal als dieses dieses kleine
und das licht unter anderem stichwort
innere werte etwas etwas verrückten der
fotos fotosensor ist beweglich innerhalb
dieses geräts und soll dadurch wackler
beim fotografieren und filmen
ausgleichen
es gab es ja eine lange die devise um so
größer desto besser das display jetzt
gibt es eine mini version was glaubst du
haben hier drauf gewartet wie wird es
jetzt ankommen vielleicht wird es ja
sogar der verkaufsschlager was sagst du
also ich glaube dass er auch tatsächlich
sehr viele menschen gewartet haben es
gibt ja auch schon wieder seit dem
frühjahr ein sogenanntes iphone se das
ist auch ein relativ kleines modell ein
bisschen größer vom gehäuse her als
dieses hier hat aber einen noch
kleineren bildschirm und ich glaube
jetzt werden sich sehr viele menschen
ärgern die sich im frühjahr dieses gerät
gekauft haben denn sie bekommen
ein noch kleineres handliches gerät das
super in die hosentasche passen die hand
hat und in die handtasche
das dass du jetzt gesagt und sie
bekommen aber fallen dieses kleine gerät
mit einem deutlich größeren bildschirm
bei dieser bildschirm ja bis an die
ränder reicht während beim se oben und
unten noch so dicke rahmen ist und unten
ist die home taste mit dem mit dem mit
dem fingerabdruck sensor also ich glaube
das wird ein richtig großer erfolg weil
ganz viele auf so ein kleines handliches
gerät gewartet haben
das heißt welches modell würdest du
jetzt für welchen käufer empfehlen und
wichtig auch der preisliche unterschied
zwischen dem 1
ja also das stichwort handlich habe ich
ja schon gesagt wer wirklich ein handy
haben möchte was ganz bequem in die
hosentasche passt der kann natürlich auf
jeden fall hier zum 12 mini greifen das
liegt dann bei 778 euro im moment das
liegt jetzt an diesem comment
mehrwertsteuer zahlen die wir haben 778
euro und dieses gerät ist definitiv für
jemanden gemacht der richtig ernsthaft
damit auch filmen fotografieren oder
generell auch arbeiten will und der ganz
gezielt auf diesen großen bildschirm
haben will
denn das ist nicht nur groß sondern auch
relativ schwer und da muss man ja auch
um das wirklich dann in kauf zu nehmen
muss man eben auch diese funktion
ausnutzen denke ich dann sind wir aber
hier bei 1200 euro und etwas und in der
best ausgestatteten variante sogar bei
1000 über 1500 da sind wir also in den
bereich das ist schon der bereich also
ein preis wie bei einem wie bei einem
kleinen tablett letztlich genau
und wer aber dann das große und das
kleine nicht will kann ich ja immer noch
dann die andere variante
nein das ist natürlich dann das iphone
12 in der mittleren variante das
natürlich die alternative ist für alle
die sagen ich möchte nicht dass ganz
kleine oder so ein ganz großes dann gibt
es ja noch dieses das eben wie du schon
sagtest seit ende oktober im handel ist
also für jeden apple fan was dabei
dankeschön sven stein für die vorführung
hier studieren verlieren
danke dir mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren